alana i feel like you are um slowly
transitioning to
like a reboot of storm but it's like one
that we shouldn't do which is just she's
white
it's probably a bad idea i don't feel
like that would go down very well
i mean white muted i'm muted storm is a
very uh
verbose character oh that's strange yeah
it doesn't work
did you hear that thunder no i mean
you've still got you've got
you've got yeah yeah you fixed it oh
you've got superstorm
who's you know less offensive as a
casting choice
that works well yeah i do that
would you want to play look look you
you've you've begun your career into
look at me i'm acting both you and
[ __ ] greg miller get out of my i've
taken over very high stanzas troy if
you'd made it through the auditioning
process you'd be in the game what can i
say
okay i was recording them
[ __ ] they said take chances man i was
willing to take chances
for the record i wasn't invited you
weren't invited so
you've got the bottom of the ladder here
then the lowest rung
represented in troy and then success on
the ladder represented by
a line thank you appreciate that yeah i
i aspire to be greg one day
um where my acting career is concerned i
just hope that i can
be greg miller i feel like a lot of
young voice actors are saying that these
days i'm seeing it all over the time
he's in everything how do i turn this
off how do i leave i don't know
he's wait am i watching this thing lego
games he is
yeah i was actually what i went to
because when i before we worked together
one of the things i like to do one of
the things i like to do troy knows this
i've told him this
i go and i will watch a bunch of any
actor who i know is cast
so i can rewrite the script for their
specific kind of vocal shape
and i did that with greg and i was like
greg like have you been
have you been in anything is there any
reference like because i like otherwise
i'm just going to watch a bunch of kind
of funny you know
and he was like yeah yeah there was this
and he was said he sent me the like the
lego games he was in
and yeah he was pretty cool is he is he
he's the polka dot
man isn't he in in dc or something it's
something like that he was first a
citizen in par i know i should not know
his idea he was just
oh my god oh my god look at me
and then then this is what really gets
me this is what gets me about greg
miller
this is beautiful that guy has the
audacity
by the sheer act of taking off his shirt
yep creates a a comic book character
yep that then gets licensed
to be it again it's good
it's it's diabolical if he wasn't
such a just just a a a hideous human
being
he's awful he's famously a terrible
person yeah no that's that's true nobody
knows
72 puppies he's drowned mm-hmm 72. 72.
you're going for well yeah as of
yesterday
related i saw cruella before yesterday
it was actually five
so yesterday was just a massacre huge
day for greg
oh somewhere right now in the bay area
greg miller's going
he doesn't listen surely
what happened did he just now get to
australia
what is what do you mean she's she's had
some stuff she has other she has other
uses over time
i guess a while ago like like long
enough for
you we should probably forget it what
was your what's your take i haven't seen
it by the way but what's your take
on like a week ago so oh really okay
yeah
i definitely remember that there is a
disney related lag because of all my
frustrated australian friends getting
spoiled on mandalorian every week
oh yeah what's it like um i i was like
just incredibly impressed by the
soundtrack
and like set design the fashion like
it's a very both visually and auditory
impressive film
funnier than i expected the things that
i was like but it was a good time i had
fun watching it
good movie to watch with your dad in
case you're wondering
no sex scenes no that's the weirdest
thing i've ever seen
yeah it's a bad time that's why you get
a sex scene with your parents you're
just going
and like you're even an adult right even
as an adult especially as an adult
because now it's known that both of you
you know have experienced that
i'll never forget this in a drive-in if
you remember what a drive-in is
i was it was my sister and i fashioned
yeah
thank you covid uh my parents were like
hey
uh we're gonna go see a movie called the
officer and the gentleman
i was like oh okay and me being the very
curious kid that i was looked it up in
the paper which is where you used to
look up
movie sorry i'm sorry sorry paper
newspaper it's a thing that it was an
alternate use paper sir
i did and the street extra extra
yes and so i looked in the paper
pictures
i just assume it's newsies speaking of
good stuff on disney plus the newsies uh
stage recording
while he's on there it's very good i
don't know um
so i i'm i'm doing something i'm
multitasking i shouldn't but i'm looking
after you guys don't you see the officer
in general
um with your parents officers and
gentlemen and in like calling off the
hit
he was like it's about to be 73 and i'm
like greg for the love of humanity
please
it's like a doggo man he went backwards
at least he went back down to one and
yeah i
of very confusing tweets sent to him
yeah yeah my description
please listen no don't do it try don't
do it
do not nobody who's listening please do
not
act greg miller at game over on twitter
don't do it and say don't do it greg do
you love dogs question mark
hashtag pwl please don't do that that's
that's
that's nothing that we want you to do do
not not at greg miller on twitter at
gameovergreggy.com
mike that's the point we're saying we
don't just take pwm we don't endorse
that
actually not endorse that at all so
anyway
um i look in the paper and under an
officer and a gentleman
i see a letter here's a picture of uh
who was louis costa junior and and
richard gere
and and he's in the the navy thing and
there was a big
letter r and i didn't know what that art
necessarily stood for but i knew what it
represented and it represented that was
a naughty movie and so i was very
confused that my very christian parents
were going to see
an r rated movie and here we were my
sister and i were
in the station wagon and we're just
watching this movie and not really
tracking along with what's happening
there's a guy
he gets a tattoo
well they didn't have babysitters
there's like it was either it's like
look we could buy a tub of popcorn or we
can watch the 13 year old down the
street
with with our kids and they're like ah
popcorn huh
so they did they did that and so there
was this one scene in the movie where
like
okay kids go lay down in the back of the
station wagon
that's what we had to do and of course i
was like yeah i told her we're gonna
listen to her parents and then my sister
and i both just do
sure and we saw boobies
and we both probably felt two different
things at that time
but maybe not that's an okay thing
because it was weird like why did you
guys watch this and they said bad words
and stuff
but when you're watching it when you're
like of the age where you're probably
having sex
and you're aware of what sex is and you
watch a sex scene with with
with your parent a movie that has a sex
scene with your parents and you both
have the question in your head but
you're not going to ask you're like
dude do you do that you but you haven't
thought of that everybody i've never had
that question i've never ever
in my life see i really i relate to that
for sure
you're so right troy about like i
remember
i remember um just to put that in
context i i
my sister and i are both born early
september which is like
pretty spot on nine months after like
christmas new year's
um and one day i asked my dad you know
i find it suspicious that there
there's a you know two two two points
don't make a good data set but
they are exactly like we're born two
days and five years apart we have almost
the same birthday
so i said like i feel like there's
something there
uh and he goes with you
i don't know but i can tell you i
remember the thrust that made your
sister
that was his response and i remember to
this day
killed me laughing i was like see this
is what makes you different from most
other dads
i don't think that i look for that i
don't think
why like you know it's not like you get
to live in denial that
that is a fact unless there's like a
oh no you do live in that denial yeah no
there's like there's an explicit and
there's
don't you remember the simpsons with
grandpa going
i had sex you know like
it's it's it's a fact of life you've got
to sell the tv rights to your dad i
think i've said that before
but you need to like you need to write a
book a novel
uh i don't know oh my god it does sound
good
just a coffee table book of just like
things that your dad said with zero
context
i actually did start making a list at
one point where i thought it could be
fun to do like a rolling youtube
uh just like random reflections
uh of you know little kind of pearls of
wisdom that i
that i i i picked up because he was you
know he was as
as i'm demonstrating he was all about
the direct
like i remember i think i may have even
told the story once when we were making
a
thing for our yard like a kind of wooden
sculpture type thing it's technically a
bridge but it's just a decorative thing
and it's just a little thing he felt
like building in the yard
and so you know i had all these little
thin strips of wood and they required
like a thousand little
uh drill holes to put screws through and
so
um you know he was really quickly just
like vroom well
at some point i was like i don't
remember what i said but something made
him go
i would not advise touching the the
drill bit uh
because he just drilled like a thousand
holes with it and it was like what would
happen and he goes
well you know what okay fine go ahead
and touch it uh and it's like you know
touch it and it's 5 trillion degrees and
you're like that's [ __ ] and he's like
and now you know and it was like that
was pretty much all the list and it's
done there's no like hard ass quality to
that at all it was like he
he was obviously not going to let me
kill myself or severely injure myself
dude i i gotta tell you the the amount
of trust respect and restraint that that
shows within your dad
is massive because there is just an
inherent
pull for for me to like keep traveler
from harm
even though it's like you gotta bonk
your head man you you gotta do it right
now and i've watched him just do stuff
where he's right now he's at the point
where he's like i'm gonna do this soft
first it's like okay i got a good
feeling on that
but the fact that your dad like we just
got back from yosemite and that entire i
realized
i had this view of of most places like
oh it's an amusement park
you know it's like this is a you pay an
admission and you go inside
it is it is the wilderness and it is 100
there are people stop there like there's
bear right there and i was like
as part of the ride they're like oh no
he'll probably kill you i was like ah
it is it is a place it's much like you
would feel at home a lot it's a guy
telling me
within the jaws of the bear i don't know
he's really pissed he's trying to eat me
right now
it is a place that is actively trying to
to or to harm you
and it's gorgeous and it's beautiful but
it is it is the wilderness
and traveler was incredible we
stood in a stream for an hour and and
skipped rocks it was just like
the most beautiful serene natural thing
but it was super hard for me not to
just be all around him and just let him
be exposed to elements that could
potentially
scrape his knee or whatever so the fact
that i'd be like you know what man i
need you to touch that because that's
gonna
imprint on you a lesson that is
unilaterally transcendent and
applicable to so many things in life so
please touch it well and in fairness you
know
my mom my mom uh
he was a surgeon too so that he's like i
could fix
whatever you [ __ ] up that's true he's
like yeah i guess yeah that's what i
care about
so i feel like
no there was a very healthy tension
there i think because my mom was
generally the one who was like are you
watching is he safe or
and and and so i it never felt like
there was no safety net my mom was
very much the voice of like you i want
to make sure that you don't
die right now and my dad would be there
he's fine and like sometimes
she was right sometimes he was right oh
he's actually hurt
yeah like he's asleep right okay yeah
he's unconscious
he's been sleeping for a week can i ask
each of you a question on this
video game podcast player which listen
hi i'm a lot of peers that's my
good night everybody um what's your
dumbest injury
um i got a good one okay you go first
it's it's very on topic for this subject
because my when i was growing up
actually i love this so inspired
directly by the genius of tim schaefer's
full throttle
the only game that my dad and i ever
played together he went and bought a
harley-davidson wow
and he had he had ridden motorcycles as
a kid like because they're obviously
cheaper than cars and
at some point it was like you know this
is my preferred method to get around
but then he not ridden a bike in ages
and just decided you know what i wanna i
want like a pleasure cruiser
so i was probably you know 13 or
something
and he said you don't want to just go
ride around you know it's like saturday
afternoon
and the reason he had bought this
particular one the heritage soft tail
classic
was because in full throttle you know
ben's bike has like a thousand tailpipes
that are all crazy and it kind of looks
like the iron
throne you know and um and so the
heritage soft tail classic had a few
very showy tailpipes kind of the closest
that you could get
and it's a very loud very typical harley
davidson obnoxious motor
that's just like there's one word going
through my head right now and you know
exactly what it is
it's it's a uh i got a few guesses uh
oh well yeah of course yeah duh that
should have been the first
um but yes and it's so accurate like um
although as my dad pointed out that's a
safety feature of motorcycles because
you can hear really hard you're really
hard to see uh you're a small target and
it makes it impossible to miss
a lot harder to side swipe interesting
um they are nonetheless
very annoying give him a horn
you don't want to lay on the horn all
the time though constantly um
but uh so point being i guess it's
effectively the same
so the um the first thing he said we get
a
ride on the bike and he's like this
tailpipe when we get off we're going to
ride for like an hour when we get off
this tailpipe is going to be like 5
million degrees
so yeah don't don't be stupid you know
um and we went and wrote to an old
friend
in a part of town we had used to live in
and and and i remember
pull up on the bike and they come out
and everyone you know wants to check it
out or so i'm standing there next to it
and i'm just kind of like rocking in
place and i felt myself
roll on my heel up against and felt like
and i was so freaked out that i was
disobeying his one very clear thing
that i just kind of bit my lip and
slowly pivoted off and didn't say
anything and then when
when we you know everybody 20 minutes
later like part of company i like snuck
away with my friend i was like do you
have ice or something because i really
think i just
severely damaged my leg dad on our way
home can we
get some ice cream and go buy i don't
know a first care unit yeah exactly
like i i i and and i did i i
feel like you probably shouldn't do this
because i just thought well maybe i can
reverse it so i like grab a bunch of ice
cubes and start
rubbing it on the skin so it's like i'm
traumatizing it the opposite direction
now relative
so anyway we we finally we finally get
home and it's like starting to look
really bad it's like what happened here
and i just like broke down i was like
i did the one thing you told me not to
do and i basically had too much pride
uh in making the mistake he was like
that's the point of that is that you're
okay
like it's not a rule you didn't you're
not upsetting me
it's not like i made this rule he felt
bad that i was ashamed to admit it
but it the whole rest of that it it
fully blossomed into a
full-on second-degree burn and it was
the most ugly thing
and i i still have a scar that's like
the shape of an eye really it's
very very very faint now but for
years and years it was like especially
if i got any kind of sun there was just
this
really awkward looking like i got it
kind of got to show it now
yeah oh you can't see it anymore no uh
you just said it
was you could i was still visible to
this day
now as much as i would love to show
so yeah i've injured myself in really
stupid ways a handful of times but that
was one where i was very ashamed of what
i had done uh and then i think i
actively made it much worse
i might oddly enough is kind of similar
but
far less i my sister had a curling iron
and i was like i wonder if this is still
on and instead of just
feeling if it was hot i put it to the
side of my face
i went whoops and it scarred and it was
just like right there
it's not a great idea that may be the
dumbest i've had a lot of of like
i i tried to jump onto a stage
this was recently we were in
philadelphia and we were doing a live
show
and i i was out in the crowd and i was
running back up on the stage i was like
i can do this i'm not 45 and bunk and i
did it and i missed
and my shin hit the corner of the stage
and i was like good night everybody i
walked off stage
and i was like oh it was bad i should
have gotten stitches and i didn't
and it's i still have a scar i can
probably show you sure you do
can you show yourself trying to choice
for me it's a podcast yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] i don't know austin's got all these
other podcasts he does i'm all talking
it's not committed
there it is i actually can see all right
very good
i can't van damn like i liked how uh i
liked how
jim gymnast that looked to you were very
pointed toes that looked very natural
total nimble someone's gonna put that on
google i'm sorry about that troy
[Music]
what's your dumbest injury yes we have a
topic dumbest injuries
i got two i got two i think probably so
the one
the one you all know about is i broke my
foot
in captain america's fantasy
place yes because it's the it's the
location they shoot like the dancehall
scenes in those movies
this is recent this was very recent yeah
this was we were doing i was doing uh
doing an interview for the bbc in there
like and they chose it was this
cool backdrop but it was like this quite
dilapidated old dancehall that was just
used basically as background for tv
shows and movies
what do you call the thing that they put
you in the thing
the thing you saw me in i don't know
what it's always that cold like as a
brace to boot it's like a big
boot yeah is that not weird and being in
the uk because
why would you call that a trunk
solid continue your story i apologize
it didn't mean i couldn't play soccer
for a bit so you know it was devastating
um i liked i liked the just quiet
admiration of your response to that
moment yeah like solid well that's one
reason
that's one reader of my expression yeah
one reads one possible read
um the but yeah the other one i guess
was uh yeah big
really bad sporting injury i got as a
kid broken arm
but it was doing the sack race which is
the least impressive sport
did the second race make it to america
of course it did you do
yeah we call it potato sack race
race so you definitely have that
not super interesting i'm not very good
storyteller i don't know if it's coming
across
yeah you're notoriously awful at telling
stories that's what they say about my
award-winning storyteller i can't tell a
[ __ ] story yeah sorry
wow my dumbest is uh
i cut my hand open with a hacksaw
trying to cut through a kirby amiibo
um i do still have the scarf on my hand
she's wanted
to see it i still have the kirby amiibo
no
that is what was what was the bit that
was for was that for like a video or
something
it was for a feature for ign yeah so
when i was waiting for them to
finish my visa paperwork which took
forever
i was stuck in limbo it was like a well
we don't know when you'll have it
but don't go anywhere you can't do
anything or work anywhere else
like it was very months of not being
able to do anything while i was waiting
and so because i was like well because i
can't really move on with my life and
this has taken
six months i think it took i was like
can i just start
can i start writing features so that i
can get paid
and uh wait a minute wait a minute they
were doing all this with no money
well i you don't get paid while you're
waiting for the visa no
so that no it's a big process yeah yeah
it takes a very long time i got the job
in may and started in november um
yeah it took a long time but uh yeah
they they were like well let's give you
a bunch of features
so you have stuff to work on and they're
all things that i could do remotely and
that didn't have to be
uh evergreen or did have to be evergreen
well it didn't have to be timely so i
could do whatever and they were like i
don't know cut them an amiibo in half it
was around that time i guess so that's
what i did
and it was really hard parts of your
hand yes
it was very difficult like i was like
i'll sleep i did that like
whatever why it would have gotten views
for science
because people would be like huh why did
you do that or what does it look like on
the inside
is it is it like a tree i mean are there
any rings
it's like think of it like an unboxing
video
i'm just it's going to lead to look
inside it leads to the natural
conclusion of like
the unboxing of a human cadaver and then
you're going to have to upgrade to live
subjects from there and it's just
that's what i'm doing down the rabbit
hole yeah yeah but uh it was really hard
and so i had i had changed through
multiple tools and ended up with a
with a hack so i was trying to cut
through it and just sliced my hand
it bled a lot it was not not a good time
pretty stupid injury
do you need stitches i don't think i
went to the doctor for it
also you know what i did i and i had to
get a tetanus shot
but i was like several days late because
i was like wow this hurts a fair bit huh
because it continued to hurt really bad
so yeah they made me get it when it's
like bright red and hot to the touch
these are not good signs it's pretty bad
yeah
that would be my dumbest one but also
when i was a uh i think i was
one my mom had put on a bath for me and
then got a phone call and i decided to
step into the bath even though it was
exclusively hot water
um and burned my feet and had to go to
the hospital but my feet are completely
fine she was like
confident that she had destroyed my feet
and was a terrible parent and
you know was going to parent jail uh but
i don't have any recollection of it even
happening
when they were one i think ah
it's pretty young yeah young enough that
i could get in a bath but not young
enough that
no not old enough that i remember
anything happening you
lo you become a new person from an
epidermal standpoint
every 30 days that's crazy to me i think
on an atomic level
you replace every atom in your body i
think you're
not done for the whole thing i think
he's talking you're talking skin right
i'm talking skin yeah i think it's skin
is eight years sorry sorry skin is
as you said three days uh full body is
eight years
that that right there is
first of all i feel like we all just got
high
that is the feeling that tends to set in
exactly this moment
it's like it definitely has that kind of
stuff in a garden
vibe
what makes you you that is the most
fascinating concept right well you were
just
you don't exist you're a concept that
your brain has decided to believe
like there's no is that is that that's
that's like
a derivative of solipsism right it's
where it's like i only exist because i
think that i
it's a biological exist right the sense
of self is is a construct invented by
our brains there is nothing but out of
necessity though like right
exactly yeah i know for sure for sure
solipsism is
is different just for the records is the
fact that you can't
it's it's difficult to basically you
think that that's true conclusively
that you are not the only thing in
existence like i
i can't i can't truly prove that this is
not all
uh matrix-style illusion and that you
guys are all
some days it has the ring of truth
doesn't it yeah sometimes like
i just like that we just go back to that
wardrobe because i
had a lot of leather in the early 2000s
and i still want to wear it
you can troy you can make that a new one
they're making it now you're out in the
farms it'll go down great
yeah hi troy
pears are coming in nice
[Laughter]
i uh i i always found it interesting
how police will say on your person
every time i hear the phrase on your
person i feel like i have an existential
crisis
because i have a position that would be
the perfect response though
uh miss pierce do you have uh any drugs
on your person well let's talk about
what on your person
on my person what does that mean like
what yeah
two hours later the two of you are like
sitting on the side of the road and just
like
[Laughter]
yeah always gets me yeah it helps you
deal i just don't understand what the
question even means anymore
i uh total total about face but i
it's on the subject since you mentioned
seeing crewella which i wasn't
particularly
[ __ ] forgot about that i wasn't crazy
about it either but i thought it was
funny um
it's just a funny thing that it was like
i i think it was the the uh pitch
meetings
uh screen video where they were like
where they were like
um you know we're making a character
origin story that
has to somehow be a protagonist but yet
like theoretically is leading towards a
character that wants to skin animals for
their
to make coats that like like how how are
we making a protagonist oh
next to someone that's much more evil
you know like let's just make emma
thompson just that much worse and we'll
forget about the
path that cruella is supposed to be on
is it thompson
okay this is where i get confused
there's too many emmas atmospheres
emma stone see emma thompson was the one
who's
emma also isn't emma thompson the bad
guy she's like
wait a minute unless i'm getting my
british actors like the kenneth
the the frequent collaborator of i'm not
first of all i will not be corrected on
female actors by austin wintry who
believes that everybody is
who is it is a joke all blondes look the
same or whatever
it is with thompson yeah naomi watts is
in cruella de vil
wait i thought that was true and that
sounds right there's emma thomas and
emma thompson correct emma thompson
emma thompson and emma thompson is the
british actor that
was like lifelong friends with um the
dearly departed
uh uh alan rickman correct not yeah i
have
no idea like yeah thompson is the
kenneth
she's in like all of his stuff and she's
all but
was she married to kenneth branagh when
they married
well they were married when they did
what uh dead again which is offended
it's one of the first things he directed
and it's brilliant it's his great
hitchcockian
goes back and forth he's a severely
underappreciated director
agreed i i think he is an absolutely
correctly appraised
doer of a russian accent though it is
it's it's like it's like one step above
john malkovich right
it's it's it's pretty what's his name
what's his name stepping up this week
ray winston
doing bob hoskins from enemy of the the
gates
oh yeah um i love that movie it's great
but like the bob you know the bob
hoskins accent he does that do you
remember the bob hoskins russian accent
ray winston 100 is doing the bob hoskins
accent
in um i think kenneth bretta was good in
what was the uh
uh the new jack ryan movie with uh chris
pine right he was
uh i think it was cool jack he directed
that that checks out
jack creature jack
one of them's tom cruise i don't know
jack creature was tom cruise but yeah
well anyway i'm gonna grab this one and
pull it back
so um normally the one who's responsible
for derailing everything but sure
people can grow i have an arc on this no
you don't um
well i just because i can backpedal i
show glimmers of a potential you're not
changing
that reminds me so um i
um i have not seen the tomorrow war
and i don't know that i feel
particularly motivated
you're better off yeah but something i
have a friend who's a screenwriter
and and he watches he's one of these
people that sees every movie ever made
and
and so everyone he has kind of like a
following of friends on facebook that
are always curious his reviews because
he you know he can be pretty
thorough and thoughtful in his reviews
um
and he has made comments like this in
the past and i always feel the need to
jump in and speak kind of collectively
on behalf of our industry
because one of his critiques of that
film was
the writing felt like a video game that
was hit one of his comments
should do service to video game right
for sure
but well i would say thank you but
here's well here's what he made i wish
it was not glorious
what he meant was the drama
it never felt motivated by character it
was a succession of side quests that's
exactly what he meant he goes this movie
felt like
we have to go here and do a thing and
chase a macguffin and now we're going to
go do
another thing and now do another thing
and now do another thing and then like
look we reached the end
and in his mind that this like
kind of parade through a succession of
side quests
has a video game quality and as i
thought about i thought okay well let me
my knee-jerk reaction is to do the same
thing you guys just did
oh how dare you definitely but then i
thought well you know
how many video games are truly like
obviously games like
you know
god of war the last of us thomas
representatives
right now no that but actually funny
enough i
all three of those are unironically
invoked like that there are
games that are brilliantly written no
matter what you stack them up against
but i don't think it's unfair to say
that most games i think as i thought
about it more
issue with most i don't understand the
criticism surely i mean
character character is revealed through
action i don't really
think they rely well exactly that's what
i was gonna say they rely on the agency
of the player
knowing that the investment comes
through doing um
okay that's all action cinema that's
that's that's everything that
that's what their character is driven
through action there's so many games
that i've played
where i was like oh my god it's amazing
and i love the writing and then i go
back and i like like i'll sit with like
a screenwriter friend and watch
portions of it and they are so cold to
it and i realize
it's because they didn't do it they
didn't feel what it's like to do it and
i thought
is that does that mean that so here's
one of two possibilities i'm curious
your thoughts
number one does that mean we give
a pass to weak writing because of our
agency or does it mean
that it's not weak writing it's writing
that is in it is
it is it is taking use it is for taking
advantage of the medium for which it's
written
i think
if you don't know if you're not in the
medium and it sounds it's a dismissive
tone i'm taking maybe but i feel like a
dismissive tone was initially taken by
the other party like
oh for sure and i don't it's 100 i don't
defend that or condone that of course i
understand
and i'm sure he doesn't
he's just he's he's of that he's of that
type that thinks games are for kids and
movies are for adults you know like
anxiety he's like every previous which
is obviously ridiculous
yeah but it's but it is something it's a
it's a system that repeats like it's 100
you can go back to like when television
was starting you can find all the radio
writers who were saying the television
massively ruined the power of the spoken
word and you can go back to
movies and television you can you can at
every single turn of the
there were people in the cave doing the
cave paintings
who didn't like these upstarts trying to
make sculptures outside you know what i
mean like there has always been
it's it's it's true it's true to me you
don't
if you look if you want real examples of
like when writing in games has really
been bad
it's often when they hire movie screen
writers because as you say it's
completely different skill set it's a
completely different
mode of telling stories um and yeah
i i guess i really do i do have an issue
when i see
like for me i i literally used to do a
20-minute talk at
conferences of um why die hard is the
best video game script ever written
the die hard action movies in general
but die hard in particular
is such a brilliant narrative built
around
action beats and around action revealing
character
script is the best video game i'm saying
that you can learn a lot
i mean that was the name of it because
it was it was a pitchy kind of thing but
like
the the meaning is there's like there's
lessons in it so like you look at die
hard
literally the entire character arc of
the protagonist is he starts by being
told by a yuppie
how to fly properly and then he ends by
making a yuppie literally fly out the
window
like it's all action there is no
the writing is unpretentious and
straightforward and just kind of
moves the plot along in a lot of cases
minus a couple of cool catchphrases
but the structure and the way action is
scripted
to tell stories to tell character in die
hard is genuinely incredible
there's waypoints there's they use a
nude calendar on a wall to teach you the
layout of nakatomi plaza you understand
when you're watching that movie you know
where everything is because they walk
past it and the camera
like lets you know literally there's
like a it's like a new poster in a water
wall and they use that several times to
kind of tell you where you are
calendar so much good stuff in that
movie and so i would
like to that's a great that's a great
point and i would put jurassic park in
the same
category it's basically famously one as
well that breaks every screenwriting
rule that hollywood
tends to stick to in terms of like its
pacing and its act structure
jurassic park you have to work very hard
to fit that into the kind of
save the cat style three-act structure
like it's a reason and it's also very
little
people's care people's growth
um is through their deeds and their
actions
more than like just the way that alan
grant's body language evolves in
relation to the two kids
alone as a statement of arc versus like
let's talk about it or let me expose it
my feelings it so yeah by the same token
a single line of dialogue
does the most to reveal who
um uh what's his name the the oh my gosh
planet earth um hammond dr hammond is
one single line of dialogue it's the
wrong atom
connection to go yeah but
austin i think you pointed this out to
me as well the ice cream scene
i love that scene is one of the most
revelatory in a single line of dialogue
next time we'll do better yeah it's
funny because i always heard this
criticism of that scene of like oh it's
just a it's just like
a scene stuck in there to be a
commercial for all their merchandise and
i was like that's the
it's the tragedy of everything that he
that slipped out of his fingers like
that's the point he's
and the fact that that's that creation
of the commercial product is the thing
that continuously trips him up
it's yeah it's it's i think i think
screenwriters and
can often fall into the trap of thinking
that wordiness equals
content and there's the trite thing the
show don't tell thing and
and that'll only get you so far but like
i think what's interesting with games
and with action movies in particular
is you go one step further than show
don't tell you go
like acts don't show you know like like
it's there's a very direct and specific
it's why i genuinely always point people
towards like action movies
[ __ ] children's cartoons like uh
video games like stuff where
there is a brevity because it has to be
for various reasons we can learn so much
from
i want the aaa writer on the podcast to
give her her opinions on this because i
think your stuff probably
there's so much things that i wish that
i could talk about that i keep going
through my head and being like can i say
that
can you talk in general terms can you
break off a little and talk about this a
bit i'm interested yeah
i have to i have to say i have i have
five minutes
just because i want to give you a heads
up all right it is a shame well i wanted
to ask the question austin of
is there is the suggestion that
very good solid dodge is the suggestion
that the existence of
side quests uh equals inherently bad
right
is that what the suggestion is that if
you can go and do stuff that is not
related to a main quest that that is bad
writing
because i would not agree with that at
all that that's
is that what the article is asserting i
think what he
i'm not i'm i'm very much extrapolating
so i'm just kind of
inventing a character at this point and
trying to use them as a mouthpiece for
dissent
is this twice i don't understand he um
uh because what i think i what i think
is a
fair summary is that
um content of any kind
is like sufficient we have to make it
longer
so the like we have to have a minimum 40
hours of gameplay so let's throw a bunch
of superfluous content in there
um that just adds to the run time you
know
whereas film by virtue of its medium it
tends to have the opposite mandate like
how can we shave five minutes out of
this cut how can we shave 10 minutes out
of this cut
so it's often a winnowing down to the
most diamond grade material whereas
at least in the old-fashioned cliche aaa
model it was the opposite
let's pad this this is too short um
obviously things are changing
is definitely not true in my experience
i was told really early
this game will end up being way longer
than you think that that that's a common
thing that
in triple a writing they're like we
think it's going to be this
double whatever we think it's going to
be on the indie side too like we
we always set out to make a two or three
hour game
knowing full well because we're trying
for two or three we'll hit like six
seven
yeah also there's there's also evolution
of like
longer doesn't automatically equal
better today the way
uh a cynical executive at a publisher
might have said so 10 years also
i've definitely seen movies with padding
have you ever seen anime come on why but
hold on
i'm curious why is it that the you can
double the time what what what ends up
happening is it that you can't string
the two things together as easily as you
thought
or no it's just that everything that
you're you're having
conversations about your writing ends up
taking longer
than you expect it to like there's no
there's no logic behind that other than
people being wrong in their estimations
it's just that you'll there's no like oh
we couldn't string these two things
together we need to add more stuff in it
is just the stuff we have
is longer than we thought it would be
when you actually put it into the video
game
interesting probably pacing just you
have to
you can't just throw dialogue at players
it has to be slowed down but well like
things like sideways are concerned i
don't think any of it
on any of the games that i've even
consulted on has been padding it's all
been someone had a really cool idea and
they're like oh we should totally put
that in that's neat and they really
wanted to have the side quest in none of
it's ever been
we need more side quests they're all
just cool ideas
ideally yeah i mean i've seen how like
you create one system and in order for
that system to feel like
it's robust enough to warrant being a
system
now you have that system now exist in
all five of your different locations
within the game
and then well [ __ ] now we ended up
making it a scalable system now
so you get level one two and three of
that system but that's now
scales exponentially across all five of
those regions
and so there's 15 but then you also have
to so i can see how all of a sudden this
one was like wouldn't be great if we
just had this
one little thing how it becomes a system
and that system becomes
and i can imagine the frustration when
it is
this is this this is just an idea that
we had to be kind of cool
it's going to be a great feature and
that feature becomes a system
and that system becomes a drain on the
resources whether it be time money or
people
and then next thing you know the full
life cycle of that thing is it gets cut
yeah that's you want to pitch something
that has four
legs let me tell you be prepared for it
to be cut
look how long it took for dogs to
actually become a mechanic
conversation on that note i gotta bail i
love you all very dearly i love this
conversation
um elon are you coming back are you
staying there what's happening
no i'm coming back i'll be there i just
don't know exactly when yet
okay figure it out do not at greg miller
don't do it and ask him if he loves dogs
hashtag pw
don't do it bye guys i have to
leave only a minute behind him so should
we just leave then
uh but well no i just wanted to kind of
poke at this a a
one second longer just because i mean
look i've written
on you know games full-time for nine
months now
and i've written a number of screenplays
um
and i feel like games are a much bigger
challenge in a way that i would think a
lot of screenplay writers probably don't
understand because there are all these
challenges of like well the player
or can't know this or well if we give
the player that thing then we can't take
it away because then they'll be annoyed
at a certain point in time
like there are so many things that you
have to think about in terms of but the
player
that you never have to think about in
terms of a screenplay and
i feel like that even even the action
thing like there are
so many movies now and i feel like i'm
seeing it more and more often where
dialogue is delivered with no action
whatsoever it's just people speaking in
a room to each other
and i really appreciate things like
westwood uh
where most of their monologues are
action driven
like um al swearingen is getting a
[ __ ] during one of his first
monologues and it's like
sure he's still sitting on a bed but it
is physical action he's having a
physical response while giving
a monologue where a lot of movies just
have someone standing in a room
you can't do that in a video game either
you cannot just have someone deliver a
monologue to a camera it's so much
harder because you have to be like how
do you
make the player feel like they have some
participation in this i don't even know
if you can really have successful
monologues in video games now that i
think of it i would never pitch one
that would be a hard thing to do i mean
you've literally delivered one in in our
game but that's okay
but i feel like that's not long enough
to be a mom it's not no yeah we've not
no you you definitely risk the players
interest for sure
but then you could also make compelling
arguments that like
a lot of first-person shooters are
monologues because you're basically
playing one character's perspective 30
minutes
at a time you know and yeah i think with
with no one else kind of interrupting i
think
i think we get too hung up in stories
being about words on a page
and i think that's where a lot of
problems or false comparisons come from
like
writing is so much more than just the
the wordy bit it's also the words that
you don't even put on the page the
amount of stuff that
like even i've i wrote this fantasy
novel when i was a kid that i've lost
and i'm devastated that i lost it like i
had this
full three books when i was i don't know
12 maybe
i wish i could read them now i feel like
i'd be like wow this is atrocious but i
love it uh
and it was about these kids who when
they would dream could change reality
uh but they were all like nights and
stuff in their dreams um but anyway
i don't remember what what i did with it
uh
that going through doing that stuff the
amount of [ __ ] that i had that was
in paper that i had never put into the
book just to make sure i understood it
like when was this season
what kind of bird lived here what would
they eat at this period in time like
what does this look like what kind of
clothes do you need to survive in the
cold
like all of this stuff that you don't
even write down that you have to know to
be able to get through something like a
novel or a video game especially if
there's like any kind of intense plot
you have to have so many words
you can't ever write that you'd be like
well why are we spending time
even thinking about this thing but if it
doesn't make sense in your head there's
going to be a bunch of
plot holes when you put it to someone
else it can be very complicated
screenplays it's not like they're easy
i'm not saying that i've definitely
always just found them easier than
anything else
you definitely have more yeah i think
you have more
predictable fences around your your
sandbox
uh in a screenplay you know for
especially a feature film as opposed to
like a series
yeah i i think that i think it there the
challenge becomes
comparable to you know writing a great
poem or something where it's like okay
how brett how brief
how can i avoid the fat can i
you know like it's amazing to me how
sometimes
films can you know be 90 minutes and
feel
agonizingly long but then there's other
film just because they just aren't
saying anything of substance you know
like not a pacing thing but they just
feel like my god you didn't have
the material to warrant this and then
there's others that are two and a half
hours
that fly by because they hold your
interest so effectively
how crazy though the games like as well
work as a backbone
force though i'm fascinated by the the
the all the dnd like podcasts and
youtube shows that exist
now where people just use a game rule
set and basically create like sitcoms or
or fantasy novels or like stories from
that framework
and just to look at to look at video
games and not
see all of the enormous potential and
the fact that we are still
essentially in our like silent movie era
we're still figuring out the core rule
set of making games
that's just like i can't think of
anywhere more interesting to be a
as a writer than than fiddling with this
stuff it's great
no it's all certainly how i feel about
music as well like the interactive
component of
of writing a video game score is
overwhelmingly the
the pull i love scoring films and i
still do it and tv and all that sort of
stuff but games
definitely keep me up at night in a way
that i i don't think anything else
could for that reason like the idea of
engaging the player as a co-author but
that's why i thought like
does that expose
like do i
do i inadvertently become complacent
because i think oh the player is going
to love that they caused this
and therefore if it's not the greatest
melody ever or if it's not the greatest
dialogue ever
they won't notice because of the
satisfaction of having caused it that's
why
i was just doing visuals do visuals make
movies
lazy that they never had that thought
austin have you had that thought when
making music
the player's gonna love it no matter
what i think that all the time when i dj
i'm like they're drunk i could swap
between these two songs that have
different keys
no one's gonna [ __ ] care i don't know
that i've ever thought that way about
music but i have had a few instances
where i went back i mean perfect thing
playing through mass effect uh legendary
edition
you know like in my memory
it's just bulletproof everything about
aspects is perfect yeah and then you've
got a developer in the world is your
memory like you know
and i remember going back and and um and
i've got this whole
sort of thesis on what i think the like
canon
romance options are of like this is just
the perfect
way to do it um and but begrudgingly
what that meant was um that
uh i always chose as femmeship caden
who i otherwise find to be the most
bland and ridiculously stupid character
and that's where i was like um
and when you play his romance is so
awkwardly written because it's like if
you
open the door he's instantly like so and
he just like he goes from zero to a
hundred instantly and and
i was watching my uh
well that's my point that's the point
people people because people are leaning
in they don't it's easy to give it a
pass and that's
that that's only the again i'm not i'm
sitting here trying to steal man the
criticism
yeah i'm not here actually leveling up
well i don't think that's a problem
i think no it that to me that's knowing
the medium i think um james cameron's a
brilliant example of this like james
cameron
lots of valid criticisms of his work but
like you know pretty solid
filmmaker who makes stuff people like
he's very he's literally never made a
bad film has he i don't think i don't
not my not my opinion no
and definitely very rarely made
unsuccessful i think abyss was the only
one that didn't like
absolutely blow the doors off
financially right it's still considered
a classic but it's still a classic still
a great film
um but my point is like he despite all
that
he still definitely knows when to show
off when to like do something visually
like
over here very big and actually and or
when to use like a gimmick like 3d or
when to use like
a cool visual effect to kind of still
knows when to take advantage of the
media he knows when to throw glitter at
the camera right he knows when and and
and i'm sure part of his thought process
with that
and and this is definitely i'll admit
this with game design like
where you you put those flourishes in
the moments that you know are weakest on
other fronts
but how does that relate to like this
specific example of
a really whiplashy
romance arc in well i'm i'm
well i'm i'm going back to your original
yeah mike bring it to the point we were
just
directly related podcasts
exactly let's stay focused people um no
i was going back to the thing
the thing you were saying which was
basically like you theoretically
could as a composer go well this is
technically impressive or this is
reactive and therefore i don't
necessarily have to do the best work on
every other column i would argue
actually that's part of it
i mentioned the other day like asset
revelation schedules so the idea of like
when you're planning the development of
video game you go okay i've got this
much art
i'm going to pace it so you see new
stuff a regular place
another thing we do and i've always done
in our games
is we'll then plot other areas of
interest so like when are we adding a
new mechanic when's a new character
showing up when there when there's a
joke that we know
is really funny when have we got some
new music playing and we'll
stagger those things so that we know
like okay the gameplay in this bit's a
little bit stagnant for about half an
hour
so we better make sure there's like a
really cool visual moment or there's a
this or something else that's kind of
i think it's absolutely okay to work
around weaknesses yeah 100 we do that
like you always so the player is getting
something cool every
five minutes or am i reacting to
something that you didn't say austin or
that isn't what
yeah i do think that that i do think
that that is in a sense that just
kind of that's the art history of the
work yeah yeah yeah like that's that's
you called it craft i called it oh
because i'm a pretentious indie but
still like yeah no it's absolutely
well but it's it's it but it's
fundamentally the same like
there because we do things i you know i
have a little phrase i use in my writing
all the time of covering the seams it's
the exact same thing you're talking
about
if i have to get from a to c i have to
devise a bee that helps me
mask the what would otherwise awkwardly
be a
just smashing together like especially
if we're it's a video game
like an open world you just crossfit
just crosstalk exactly give everyone a
drink is a lot of progress
yeah yep that that's true all my music
should come with
alcohol recommendations um austin i did
always i've thought about this a number
of times since you said it uh
the idea of picking between ashley and
kaiden and i have always made sure that
ashley died um and she is a space she's
the racist
she's the racist however for sure she is
something that's a death
interesting
she killed my rex and i was very upset
about it but she is more interesting as
a character
it's and it's a funny thing to think
about when you have the control over
which character you get to kill and you
are actively choosing to kill the one
who
inspires emotion and let the black slate
one live
i i've never saved her so i don't even
know if i'm selling myself short because
i hate her so much that i'm like she
must die
therefore that's satisfying to me but
then in her death am i not letting her
have an arc where she stops being a
space racist
which would be much more interesting to
watch than kate
i like her i like her arc very much uh
never seen it
yeah i i i think she's one of she's one
of my favorite characters because she's
also
she's also a genuine badass um and
to me the the the way especially the
fact that she hates shepherd in the
second game
which i assume caden does also um you
know they're they're
they're written very similarly but i've
never never had kaden not die
initially when i played through i just
was he was the only
expendable character because i found him
boring um
and um but that one like on my first you
know male
shepherd and then uh but then i i
started to develop this i
like i love the idea my my canon
uh shepard idea is that like um
she loses she loses everyone she cares
about
and it's them it's the motivator it's
the motivator of realizing like
like i need to be the final link in that
chain basically like by giving myself
over
to the the final the the grand finale
and it's essentially self-sacrificing um
i i'm following in the footsteps of
those that i love so i was like i love
the idea that
in the first one um she romances cadence
specifically because i
plan on killing him and so she has to
carry this grief
which then tees up thane
tease up thane in the second one someone
who she knows and advances
dying and because i really actually like
the
if you romance thing in two the dynamic
with him in three is quite
is quite poignant and i and i love that
that's the romance plot of the third
game is visiting him in the hospital
and then realizing you know once he's
gone um
i i the mission is all that drives me
now
uh and i've uh to me that that arc is so
much more effective on the idea that she
she
keeps losing the people that that um she
can't
she can't have that that's not her
purpose
um and but it's funny because is you
didn't
have to write all that like you
definitely put the pieces together and
built that and that's cool and that
shows you all basically exactly
what artistry that the team created a
framework for you
like i promise you there's more for you
to enjoy there
than there is in the chris pratt vehicle
uh absolutely no that's the thing that
but that's where i go
that's where i go i've gotten
huge plus i also have done a full like
garris
you know in every in every game and that
to me he's my special boy he's
he's the hero i love i love him he's a
better space cop
oh yeah he's very corrupt uh yeah i i
i i love but i to me gary says my best
friend
is became my favorite uh because uh
the the bridge scene in the third one as
a romance
is really great but something about he
doesn't have lips
what would it be like to kiss it i think
about this a lot literally
i think it would be like kissing a crab
his face is like a hard
shell because he's a young hero
but i still don't know if i want to
spoon it you know like i just
yeah so i i i this is where they created
a
tool kit they created such a sprawling
toolkit that i was able to
put it together in a way that even when
i think about it
it affects me like i just love i just
love mass effect so god damn much
but when you get down into the nitty
gritty of like how is most of this
dialogue written
how is like most of this plotting done
it's like
it's pretty like
it's you know comparable to a
uh and this is not true of all because
there's some really wonderful moments
but it's comparable to like
you know the most generic tv procedural
where they're like okay look let's just
get to the meat and potatoes because we
got a lot we got to get through um
and like that cadence story is a perfect
example of they're like we're just gonna
cut to the chase of it being a romance
so like any sense of it blossoming
there's no time for that even though we
have a [ __ ] 40-hour game
uh and so he just pretty much goes to
like
commander you want to you want to meet
me in the back
and it's like how many men do that
austin
well that's not a defense that's no
defense pretty accurate though
but okay fine but it makes for a very
unfair
it's hard to imagine getting away with
that to a commanding officer in a
military situation
yet they still do it though look i don't
doubt that i don't doubt that most guys
not most many or most are that brazen
and ridiculous
and that maybe that he is
conscientiously written to be a
realistic estimation of that
but to then also be a realistic romance
off of that means that that
has to be something that you respond to
which there are going to be women who
are
going to respond to that level of
brazenness sure but to me it felt like
right that romance subplots are often
pretty rushed like i had a
uh is it the new i think it's
new colossus i don't remember which
wolfenstein it is it might be the first
one
um where i think it's the first you're
talking dj
and his nurse at that point in time you
know she's
saving someone and and cleaning him and
giving him baths and
cleaning up his [ __ ] for years and then
classic love story dating and i was i
was not really that did
happen a lot that's happened a lot in
world wars interestingly that is
really definitely
[ __ ] for years i don't think that we
could get past that a lot
of like a lot of like soldiers coming
off the front lines
that's probably where it came from
marrying nurses yeah it's i think i
think it's actually a weird
i agree with you doesn't strike me as a
romantic situation
if i remember correctly he wasn't
speaking the whole time as well so it's
not like
given what what that character comes out
of that character's mouth when you can't
speak it's probably a
caroline probably better that's all he
says is caroline
it's amazing it's amazing you can speak
after the events of the second game i
love
bg i love dj i love that i love that i
love those games the
god that second game is fantastic yeah i
bear fantastic
they thoroughly yeah those i did not
expect them to be anywhere near as good
as they were
they're so good and austin to your point
about um i wanted to say this when you
were talking about about mass effect
being
you know the way you played in creating
your own canon that is where i see
the future of video game storytelling
going right now i think that in a lot of
cases we are making
interactive films it sub very explicitly
of that and i think that
like ratchet and clank have you have you
played like that to me
it's [ __ ] amazing but it is also it
is that it is
it is like here's story point abcd
and we're gonna dazzle the [ __ ] out of
you along the way and they do that
yeah and a lot of them a lot of games do
i think that
when speaking of that we are currently
not taking advantage of the potential of
the medium because we don't know how to
yet
like it hasn't gotten there yet but i
absolutely see a future where
like i'm very interested in dying like
two because of some of the stuff they're
doing with this
ken levine has spoken about it um where
we will be
having experiences that don't have those
set pieces that you can't rely on oh
this part's not as good so let's put
the song bird in here that'll be a cool
moment where we can't do that anymore
because
every interaction every story beat is
tailored to whatever the player has done
previously
not in a tell-tale way not in a way
that's like you know
yeah your explosion was a different
color in in a way that
because of the software that we actually
have at our disposal
that things will actually play out
completely different for completely
different people
and i think that the limits on that that
we just don't know them yet how do you
invent something
we haven't seen it yet i'm so excited to
see because if anyone if anyone's going
to make those breakthroughs it's exactly
the people who are currently working on
those things and i'm i'm excited to see
i
i am very excited to be like the second
person over that hill
like i'm not going to be i'm not going
to be the guy who does it first time and
time again mike
where as soon as somebody can do it it's
easier for everyone else to do it and
like i've seen
ken's game he's he's working on this
kind of thing
and i i saw it four years ago like i
i i don't know the thing right you need
you need the investment and that's the
other thing that's really interesting
and yeah
he will need however many years at least
four as you said like already and many
more to kind of work it out
and then there'll be a two-hour gdc talk
where they go over it
and the the the smarter kind of critics
and analysis that will happen in the
game's uh press will happen
and then we'll all rip it off and it'll
take us half a year to add that feature
to our game and that's the games
industry and that's how we've created
such exponentially
better games
that's like just how innovation works in
the human i think one thing we got very
right at the start which is different to
other industries is the games industry
has always been
aggressively anti uh
you know patents trademarking like sorry
not trademarking the the copywriting of
mechanics like
the games industry has always resisted
that would be something obviously stand
out examples of that wrong
there's obvious examples where things
have been locked in that way but like
on the whole i would say better than a
lot of industries we we've understood
where we are and i think we've also had
the lessons of things like the film
industries history
if you look how long the film industry
took to get to where it is now and how
how long that was and how much that
process was slowed down
by corporate interest essentially yeah
we
if you look at something like this what
can you name an example because i i
can't think
i'm not sure there were like five
proprietary projection
technologies and cinemas if you look at
the format wars i'm
not saying we're beyond all of that with
games but like
if you look at like what's the rep what
what is the ratio of a film screen
took 40 years to standardize
50 years to standardize that kind of
thing is what i'm talking about
and partially that is corporate stuff
partially that is
rival companies who have different
screen technologies and would muscle
other companies out of town
if you obviously got the studio system
as it once existed before the breakup
of the monopoly you've got a lot of very
i'm not putting it all on the shoulders
of capitalism i know that's my trademark
but
there are this they're they're film
industries
everything you just said is a
description of competitive businesses
and i'm saying that games are
competitive but they've also been very
good at not being overly competitive if
you look at like
the amount of information sharing say
that happens at something like gdc
where i can literally go and watch a
talk like like a good example of this is
i'm trying really hard there's a thing
that happened in a video in a triple a
game about two or three years ago that
we're
ripping off basically that we want in
our game i can go and watch a talk from
the person who invented that thing
for two hours and they will explain in
absolute detail how that was put
together
how they crossed every technical uh
border all the mistakes they made i
could go and get that information
and that level of sharing is something
that
modern industries specifically tech and
games industries have been very good
at allowing space for the idea that
somewhat the
you wouldn't get the the the guy who
invented betamax going on stage and
explaining
and sharing all of the information about
how that process went and all of their
business problems and successes with
that
to a crowd the games industry very early
on realized the only way for us to
innovate at the pace we had to
to be the next in my opinion the next
art form
required amount of amount of information
sharing that is
i'd say unprecedented i think that's
that's a big statement but i think
especially if you compare it to other
previous medias and pop cultures
it's an interesting it's an interesting
it took us less time than 45 years to
standardize the screen ratio so i'm
going to use that isn't it
we're also building off of like you
that's that's
that's you that's a little bit apples
and oranges because
the games industry is springing forward
from where it was birthed
technologically relative to all that
came before
okay something else like polygon
rendering once one game
once one once like you had the first
wave of polygon
kind of uh rendering that was happening
in like the demo scene
that to it happening in a commercial
product to happening in every commercial
product was very
quick very quick compared to most like
that's
you know we we share we we boast we show
off we go on the gdc stage and say look
how clever this is
let me boringly explain it to you for an
hour um
but yeah i i think it's also broader
trends i think information sharing in
general has got a lot easier since the
age of the internet that's a good
example of something that
we didn't invent that's not the games
industry so you're not i don't i think
i'm making us
maybe i'm overstating my case but i
think there's definitely something
interesting to the way games
culture has evolved
i'm trying to see if i can find the
answer uh very quickly here to
what might be an interesting corollary
is
there is exactly one film the jazz
singer that
was uh famously the first ever sound
film which and i was trying to look up
because something i realized i didn't
remember
uh is which studio produced that because
if if
what you're saying holds true then one
studio theoretically would have held on
to
sound as its proprietary thing for as
long as humanly possible
and that well that's what i'm trying to
find out yeah like if you look at that
period in history i
my understanding is there was there are
a couple of different proprietary
methodologies for doing sound
and if you actually look for the
widespread adoption of when
basically when movies moved over to
sound as like the standard for film
i think it was like a decade like i'm
pulling that number out my ass but i
think that's right i think basically
it's been a while since i've read that
book but like it was a while
like the the technology was not it
wasn't that you went out to sit to the
movies like a year later and everything
was sound
but there's a lot of there's there's a
lot of factors for that you know not
every production company is going to be
equipped to produce with sound straight
out of the gate
theaters obviously weirdly enough do you
know which movie theater
in the world was the first ever to
exhibit
the jazz singer and therefore the first
two it's the most
random thing i sat in that theater it
would have been a couple of years ago
speakers
they were the first to ever be able to
sync to playback
synchronized like phonographs existed
like so
speakers to the extent that you want to
label them um
existed but the idea of projecting a
synchronized sound
um the first movie theater equipped to
do that
is the it's call it's in what's called
the casino which is the large
round column shaped building on the edge
of catalina island off the coast of
of los angeles
video games still have to have those
moments we still have to have our first
synchronized audio to video moment there
there are
still so many things that we haven't
done and and to mike's point i feel like
it doesn't
the way that engines function doesn't
that directly pertain to how much
sharing is going on so like say if you
work on unreal
and unreal is is used by however many
devs and epic is offering support to
each of them and it's like well we know
this because of the way this game was
made so let's give you this advice and
this support because we've learned that
from this one like because of the amount
of
tech that's shared or is used
even oh you're right 100 that's
definitely true now
what's real and and engines definitely
speed it up but the way we
got there was through information
sharing like there was if you go back
i guess now god i'm getting old like 15
20 years when everyone had their own
proprietary engine
they were still massively oversharing i
remember being in the room
um when we added not me
much cleverer people than me added a
bunch of features that they'd seen in
gears of war
i remember that one we were working on
another game that wasn't in unreal
engine gears award come out we were in a
proprietary kind of in-house engine and
literally gec had happened and our
engineers had come back from gdc and
were like right we've got to get
yeah is the reason that gta has a cover
system like it's
so direct yeah and but but also just
like visually like the recycle
i can't off top my head there was like a
couple of like aesthetic gimmicks in
the unreal engine they made everything
green but yeah
they made everything but i i remember
the guys came back and they had like
five page like no
five pages of notebooks like explaining
how to make it that exact shade of green
or whatever it was right like and that's
and and so i think you're right i think
engines definitely
have led to a degree of standardization
but for example the thing i alluded to
earlier where i'm stealing something
from a triple a game
they're not in unity that's just that's
because
and this is something that really
matters is methodology
is actually the the massive
differentiator like if you're looking
the engines themselves realistically i'd
say unreal
let's just added a bunch of stuff that's
pushed them a little bit further ahead
but
generally the engines are about much of
a muchness in terms of like their
performance and what you can achieve
with them
it's really about the process and how
you make things and
the methodologies that you apply you can
take a technique from
i could look at an unreal tutorial and
often do to see how you would do
something in unreal
and you change a couple of words and you
trim around something that's a strength
or a weakness of your particular engine
dependent on whatever
and you you carry it through technology
matters much less than the skills and
the clever solutions that humans
invented with those tools
and that's the show that's the sh that's
this that's the [ __ ] that travels that's
the stuff the games industry
will continue to move together you know
like
and and ken will do his thing
and it'll be fantastic and
groundbreaking and it'll win all the
awards
and like i said then a couple of years
later we'll work out how to do it
unless he uh trademarks it like the
nemesis system in which case it will
never be anything i don't see
candlesticks well yes
not trademarks right i was patented yet
for the uh for the record i i
am a huge believer in what you're saying
and god knows that i've given a million
gdc talks
about how to budget orchestral recording
sessions
how to work with musicians like just
trying to share literally everything
that i've done because my attitude has
always been look i'm a composer
i i try to earn a living and to some
degree that means having something
proprietary that makes me worth hiring
versus
somebody else but i am also a gamer and
i want
games to benefit i want to play better
games tomorrow than i did yesterday
and if my knowledge might move that by
0.1 percent because some composer
heard just the right thing and went and
wrote the best score ever the gamer
the composer in me has a huge
professional admiration but the gamer in
me just straight up wants to play better
games so
for the record i am i am i'm pushing
against this to find
the the the uh the um i'm exploring this
as i like to um but i certainly agree
that that is a strength of the game
industry and i have
long said as someone who does a lot of
movies well let me just finish my
sentence and then i'll shut up
i i will say as someone who has walked
in the film community
a lot and the video game community there
is no film equivalent to gdc
and things like that and i fully
acknowledge that i do think you are
perhaps overstating
i feel like you're kind of overstating
the power of that sharing and also
understating the stagnation
that might come from trying to keep
things proprietary
um because i think certain things are
just
can't be kept online some things are
kept proprietary right some things 100
there are things i couldn't go and make
unreal engine tomorrow even if i had 100
million dollars
nor can you just go make john wick
without permission
like so people protect their ip and so
anyway i just wanted to say
i think there's a lot of nuance to this
that i don't want to just
go charging past but i promised you alan
i would shut up and now does film not
need gdc
like you can still get access to a lot
of here's how this was made via
interviews or via
director's commentary but because we
kind of
understand the mechanics of filmmaking
is it just that the film industry
doesn't
need a gdc to be like here's how we did
this thing
because everyone is experienced enough
that generally
we have a knowledge of how most things
are made
i've never actually thought of it like
that that's an interesting thought
my knee jerk reaction tells me
um that there would be no downside to if
there was a conference that i could go
to that was
all film not a fan of it but it's like
gdc
it's all directors writers composers
editors sound designers
etc etc casting directors all and like
over here steven spielberg is explaining
how
they approach the choreography and the
new west side story that he
did uh but right down the hall roger
deakins
is giving a talk about lenses or i would
also definitely
go i would 100 seconds but i think
that's that that would be nice because
cdc
is that gdc gdc is like you'll go into a
room and neil druckman is in that room
and then the next room is
mike bithell and then the next how
frequently in a smaller room in a
smaller room it's my favorite in a
different hall
the [ __ ] yeah like the shed outside
making of
making off documentaries as well are
bollocks and i think that's the thing
that
that you realize when you have got
something even interviews
interviews are bollocks they're all
about marketing spin them i i say this
as someone
who watched every making of thing i
could find about john wick before
working on it
i learned more in the first 20 minutes
sat down with chad the director
then i could have been any of that stuff
because just going to him and going
okay so genuinely like how do you put
this [ __ ] together like
and that's the stuff that you would get
in a gdc equivalent is that kind of
you know the one i always use an example
is um
volume just absolutely stole
um insomniac's core character movement
process i literally sat there
with the gdc talk going uh on a loop
because it took more than an hour to
make and coded
that kind of collider and player
navigation system
and it meant the volume felt like a
triple a game in terms of just the
fluidity of its movement and the
reactiveness
that's ridiculous that is utterly
ridiculous that is
that person on stage doing that
hour-long talk
gave me so much value they could have
charged me like a consultancy fee of
yeah tens of thousands of dollars for
that content and they didn't they just
did it for like a free pass
and then i had to pay gdc organizers to
go and see the talk it's it's
and how often does something happen in a
film that other filmmakers
won't go oh i know how they did that
whereas that's a fake game
maybe i don't know how any of it's done
like
even the things that you think you
understand you definitely don't
understand the way other studios do it
i think technically you're right on the
tools i think i'm pro i
imagine a good film director absolutely
knows
how they would shoot something they can
ask be like how do we
that no that's how they did that but i
think you lose the thought process and i
think that's
and maybe and maybe that's something
that films have moved beyond but like i
said in games at the moment
it is still so much constrained and
defined by
the clever solutions people come up with
and the thought process that leads
through it
i want to i like i'm sure anyone could
look at john
we actually we got a friend of mine
who's a storyboarder to
do analysis on john wick and like work
out okay how long does he hold a shot
for
how how does his action scenes work
whatever but
again like it's not the same as
listening to the guy talk about what he
was going for or how he approached it
and i think you can see like the um not
to mention how many
solutions came about because while they
were shooting somebody
said what if we did this instead of that
right no one intended like and i've had
that conversation
with filmmakers like talking to people
i've been lucky enough to talk to a few
different filmmakers over the years
and i've gone up to them and i've said
like well where did you get that idea
and yeah it's just well
we had to film it and we had to choose
those camera couldn't fit in that corner
so we had to do it there yeah it's like
but that's that's so powerful and so
valuable that knowledge and
and maybe that exists informally in
among filmmakers but in that case
it's less accessible to you know new
talent or you know independent people or
whatever
i get to i get the same level of access
to all of that aaa knowledge
as a triple a person attending that
conference that's really cool that's
there's still barriers to entry to ddc
oh it's super difficult it's cool
i wish i wish i wish there was less
barriers to entry for kind of
indie folks because the costs are high
but the um
but yeah it's it that knowledge sharing
is
yeah i'm very sorry very stubbornly
proud of
of that i think that's the cool thing in
the industry video game industry is cool
and the thing that like keeps me in it
is being extremely excited to see where
it goes because
i feel like there's just so much
potential that's currently untapped
so many things that we will be able to
do as hardware progresses that we
currently can't do that's just super
exciting
shout out to video games it's true shout
out to the sun going down here i've just
realized i'm saying absolutely
yeah and austin didn't you have to go 20
minutes ago i i
yeah i did but i it's my own fault
because i kind of opened up this can of
worms and then i
i really wanted to hear these thoughts
so i do have to run
all right well thank you we will see you
all
next week hooray
that was fun